Wait So speaking of friends coming to a
show I always tell people to never tell
me if someone comes to a show yeah I
hate knowing do you like KN I like know
in a long run like this where you're
doing the same show we've done it 110
times now um it helps me to see it
through new eyes I can get excited
because I know so and so's out there and
and they're English so they'll hate my
accent or they're or they're or judg or
they really judge you so they'll they'll
hate the whole show but oh man I get
that makes me ner I don't get nervous on
stage but when I know that Friends Are
Family or something and I'm like I don't
want to know yeah I don't know why get
gives me a gives me a little kick so one
time speaking of that though you
actually surprised Shawn Hayes right was
in Chicago yeah so Sean I don't know if
you got a chance to see good night oscar
but he won the Tony for it he's so
talented he's so incredible but um
that's there's us together but he uh uh
he did it in Chicago first and I knew he
was doing it he was very lowkey this
like a year and a half ago but I flew in
to see him and surprise him and I told
him that night you're going to York
right he said yeah hopefully and I said
yeah you're going to win the Tony oh my
God you like Nostradamus predicted that
it was pretty clear he yeah he's so
[Music]
[Applause]
talented thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home